COULD BE HOURS IF NOT DAYS AWAY.
>> Bret: LIVE ON HOLLY BEACH,
LOUISIANA.
BACK TO POLITICS AND THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION.
KEVIN McCARTHY IS THE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER AND JOINS US
TONIGHT.
DEMOCRATS PORTRAYING LAST NIGHT
HAD A LOT OF THINGS TO SAY
TODAY.
THE BIGGEST WAS IT’S AN
ALTERNATIVE REALITY THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE LIVING IN.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I THINK LAST NIGHT WAS
WONDERFUL.
IT WAS AN EXAMPLE IT’S OKAY TO
BE EXCITED ABOUT AMERICA.
WHEN YOU SIT THERE AND LOOK AT
NIKKI HALEY, YOU WERE PROUD AS
AN AMERICAN AND EXCITED FOR WHAT
THIS NATION HAS ACHIEVED AND
UPLIFTING SPIRIT.
SOMETHING YOU DID NOT SEE IN THE
4 NIGHTS OF THE DEMOCRAT
CONVENTION.
>> Bret: THEY HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH TONIGHT’S SPEAKER SECRETARY
POMPEO FROM ISRAEL.
>> THIS FURTHER SHOWS THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS WILLING TO
POLIT
POLITIZE THE STATE OF ISRAEL AND
USE IT AS A POLITICAL WEDGE AS
OPPOSED TO A RALLY CRY TO COME
TOGETHER FOR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR ISRAEL.
>> THE SECRETARY HIMSELF
CAUTIONED EMPLOYEES AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AT A SHOULD NOT
ENGAGE IN ANY PARTISAN
ACTIVITIES.
NOW HE IS DOING JUST THAT.
>> Bret: YOUR RESPONSE?
>> [LAUGHING].
I HAVE TO LAUGH AT SPEAKER
PELOSI.
MIKE POMPEO IS DOING THIS ON HIS
OWN TIME.
NO GOVERNMENT FUNDING IS BEING
SPENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ARE SPENDING
GOVERNMENT ON?
WE ARE SPENDING GOVERNMENT MONEY
ON 68 DEMOCRATS WHO REFUSE TO
SHOW UP TO THE EMERGENCY SESSION
THAT WE HAD LAST SATURDAY.
YOU NEVER HEARD ONE WORD FROM
SPEAKER PELOSI.
SECRETARY THIS IS ON HIS OWN
TIME.
HE IS WORKING.
IF YOU WERE TO ASK MIKE POMPEO
TO DO A VIDEO ON HIS OWN, HE
WOULD BE SOMEWHERE IN THE WORLD.
THAT’S GOODS THAT WE CAN HEAR
ABOUT THE WORK HE IS DOING
BRINGING OUR ALLIES STRONGER
TOGETHER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION CONTINUING
TO KEEP THEIR PROMISE.
>> Bret: SPEAKER PELOSI SAID THE
PRESIDENT IS A DOMESTIC ENEMY OF
THE CONSTITUTION.
SAYING YOU THE GOP FALL UNDER
DOMESTIC ENEMY OF THE STATE.
HOW WILL YOU NEGOTIATE WITH
SPEAKER PELOSI IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT?
IS THERE ANY BACK LASH FOR NOT
GETTING SOMETHING ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE AS FAR AS THAT
NEGOTIATION GOES?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
LAST TIME THEY CALLED US THE
DEPLORABLES.
NOW SPEAKER PELOSI IS SAYING WE
ARE AN ENEMY.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY THERE IS
NO AGREEMENT FOR A NEW COVID
BILL, YOU HEARD DIRECTLY FROM
HER.
EVERY TIME WE TRIED TO GET
LEGISLATION FROM THE FIRST CARES
ACT WHEN SHE HELD IT UP OR
NEEDED MORE MONEY FOR SMALL
BUSINESS SHE STOOD IN FRONT OF
HER REFRIGERATOR AND SAID NO TO
THE NATION.
SHE PUTS POLITICS BEFORE PEOPLE.
THAT’S WRONG.
WE NEED PEOPLE WHO CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
THAT’S WHAT YOU SAW LAST NIGHT.
THE DEMOCRAT STATE REP FROM
GEORGIA SUPPORTING THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT HIM TO RESIGN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHEN
PEOPLE SEE THE 4 DAYS OF THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION
AND 4 DAYS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION, IT WILL BE
CLEAR WE HAVE A BIG CONTRAST IN
AGENDA.
AFTER THE DEMOCRAT CONVENTION,
THERE ARE 3 THINGS I KNOW.
THEY HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THEY WANT TO RAISE YOUR TAXES
AND DEFUND THE POLICE.
WE LOVE AMERICA.
WE THANK THIS IS AN EXCEPTIONAL
COUNTRY.
A MORE PERFECT UNION THAT CAN
TAKE THE LIFE OF A TIM SCOTT
GOING FROM COTTON TO CONGRESS IN
ONE LIFETIME.
THAT’S AMAZING.
NIKKI HALEY.
THESE ARE THE STORIES OF AMERICA
AND WHAT BRING PEOPLE TO A PARTY
OF LINCOLN.
THE NEXT 4 YEARS WILL BE EVEN BE
BETTER THAN THE 4 BEFORE.
>> Bret: YOU ARE CORRECT.
WE HEARD A LOT OF POLICY IN THE
FIRST NIGHT OF THE RNC.
BUT THERE WAS NOT A REPUBLICAN
PLATFORM.
THE NAMES SAID WHY WOULD THE
CANDIDATES DEFINE THEMSELVES
THOROUGHLY?
BECAUSE TRUMP IS SO UNPOPULAR
THAT HIS PARTY EMBRACED HIM SO
TIGHTLY.
WHY IS THAT NOT A PLATFORM?
>> THAT’S JUST NOT TRUE.
BILL CLINTON WON BY 43%.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PLATFORM.
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
COVID AND I AM THE CHAIR OF THE
CONVENTION, WE WERE JUST DOWN IN
CHARLOTTE.
WE AGREED TO THE PLATFORM WE HAD
BEFORE.
YOU COULD NOT BRING EVERYBODY
TOGETHER.
ANOTHER CONTESTS BETWEEN THE
CONVENTIONS, OUR NOMINEES SHOWED
UP TO THE LOCATION TO ACCEPT THE
VOTE THAT WENT FORWARD.
I KNOW JOE BIDEN STILL HAS NOT
LEFT HIS HOUSE EXCEPT FOR A BIKE
RIDE.
YOU CAN’T RUN A NATION, YOU
CAN’T RUN THE MOST POWERFUL
NATION IN THE WORLD BY STAYING
HOME AND NOT GOING OUT AND
TALKING TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
YOU CAN’T WIN AN ELECTION
WITHOUT TELLING PEOPLE WHAT YOU
WILL DO FOR THE NEXT 4 YEARS.
LAST NIGHT WE WERE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP KEPT HIS
PROMISES.
BUILD THE WALL AND MAKE THE
MILITARY STRONGER AND BIG THE
BIGGEST ECONOMY.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
VICTORY AFTER VICTORY.
HE WILL LAYOUT THE NEXT 4 YEARS
WILL EVEN BE BETTER.
>> Bret: DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP
PROTESTING MAIL-IN BALLOTS FOR
STATES THAT HAVE NOT DONE IT
BEFORE, DOES THAT HURT YOU IN
THE EFFORTS TO GET SOME MEMBERS
ELECTED?
SOME REPUBLICANS OR INDEPENDENTS
CHOOSE TO MAIL IN VOTES AND YOU
NEED TO WIN THOSE SEATS.
>> I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD MAIL IN
THEIR VOTE.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAYING,
HE WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
VOTE IS COLLECTED.
A MAIL IN VOTE IS DIFFERENT THAN
AN ABSENTEE VOTE.
MAIL IN THEY MAIL TO EVERYBODY
ON THE LIST.
THE ELECTIONS DEPARTMENT DOESN’T
CLEAN THAT UP.
IN L.A. THEY HAD MORE THAN ONE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT ARE NO
LONGER THERE.
WHEN YOU GET YOUR BALLOT.
MAKE SURE YOU MAIL IT IN BUT DO
SOMETHING MORE.
TRACE IT AND MAKE SURE IT’S